if I wanted to if I wanted to sign a guy
like you okay and during that time while
you're talking a daily Wire yeah and we
sat down and I was one of the guys on
the table where would I win to be able
to attract a player like you
uh I can tell you one thing there would
have to be at least one percent upside
that's it at least one I mean that's
just where you if the sticking point is
zero percent it's like about 50 past a
certain point of net profit it's like
zero percent right when you're talking
about zero percent upside zero percent
upside zero percent upside got it if you
start with one percent you'd be ahead of
the game
okay so that's it so what you're saying
is hey I come in I like this up I don't
want you to guarantee me 12 and a half
year two years and another you know up
to six years whatever et cetera et
cetera we're gonna just tell me if I
light it up I can make 20. I can make
30. I can make 40. that's what I'm
that's your biggest thing if you could
do that yeah